[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
february has been a phenomenal month for
video games and march is gearing up to
be just as epic there's something for
everyone from wrestling to simulation
racing to role-playing shenanigans to
whatever this is march is packed with
great games that want your money and as
is the norm i found a couple of free
games for you to grab too so let's do
this
tiny tina's wonderlands any borderlands
fans in the house back in 2013 a piece
of dlc for borderlands 2 released tiny
tina's assault on dragon keep a tabletop
rpg inspired take on borderlands
storytelling that dlc was loved and now
that idea has its very own full-length
game tiny tina's wonderlands the
character creation system lets us build
a starting class and mold it how we want
around our play style just like a real
tabletop rpg wonderland gives us stats
for strength intelligence and wisdom
amongst others to hopefully make the
game more replayable as you pick a
different character and go through the
story again at its core it's all about
loot melee combat pistols smgs ars
shotguns snipers heavy weapons the full
arsenal is here and if the main
borderlands games have taught us
anything the variety of weapon
manufacturers and sheer randomness of
weapons will keep the game feeling fresh
for weeks if you have ps plus you can
play the original dlc right now as you
wait for wonderland to drop on march
25th on ps4 ps5 xbox and pc
[Music]
next the return of the graphs wwe is
back wwe 2k 22 to be precise the series
took a year off because the iteration we
had two years ago was was not good was
not good at all a new vfx engine has
been built to make the game feel more
like the tv show new camera angles and
lighting a smaller ring and a change to
inputs a simplified move system is here
to allow even the newest of players to
smash out moves like a pro as well as
adding unlimited reversals and breakers
to keep even the most one-sided matches
from being impossible to come back from
the campaign known as my rise gives us
two stories to progress through one for
male one for female mygm mode allows us
to become the general manager of a brand
and make the decisions needed to get
viewing figures up booking matches
controlling camera angles at live events
and orchestrating great storylines or
just hit people with a chair if that's
more your thing wwe 2k 22 releases on
march 11th on playstation xbox and pc
have you ever seen ghost wire tokyo a
supernatural action adventure thriller
with elements of horror set in first
person we use a blend of martial arts
and spell binding to face off with
demon-like creatures randomly tokyo is
deserted almost everyone has gone
missing in an event known as the
vanishing we wake up with a voice in our
head and new powers to harness our job
is to save the city using detective
skills and ethereal weaving which is
channeling elements at will fire wind
water all of this whilst being possessed
by a being of immense power ghostwire
tokyo is an exclusive for playstation
which is technically owned by microsoft
from before they bought bethesda on
march 25th you can try this on pc and
ps5 with it coming to xbox in about a
year
remember when gta 5 first launched in
2013 well it's launching all over again
on a third console generation this month
gta 5 comes to playstation 5 and xbox
series xns we are going back to relive
the criminal life of michael franklin
and trevor as you'd expect graphical
upgrades are guaranteed with 4k
available 60 frames per second and
improved textures and draw distances oh
and hdr and ray tracing if that's your
jam on ps5 we have haptic feedback on
your controller is confirmed too and
here's a thing you should know it's
possible to transfer your ps4 and xbox
one saves over to the next gen but it's
a one-time thing suggesting we can't go
back and forth between console
generations there's a free portion to
the re-release of gta 5 so let's move on
to our usual thing of free stuff
[Music]
gta online is also returning and if you
have a ps5 you should know that it's
officially a free game as long as you
download it within the first three
months it drops march april and may
there's no news yet about xbox having
free access but i wouldn't be surprised
to see it on game pass very soon if
you've never played gta online you'll be
given a huge chunk of money and access
to the new mechanic career builder
designed to help new players immediately
catch up with people who've played for
years buying a business right away as
soon as you step off the plane it's
guaranteed so if you want to do it all
over again in gta 5 remastered or jump
into the updated gta online for free on
ps5 keep march 15th in your mind and
hope it doesn't get delayed again
[Music]
okay another free game this is on ps5 2
bunny raiders ok i know it doesn't look
groundbreaking but give me a minute
bunny raiders is a totally free to play
game out right now it's a twin stick
shooter so your left thumb moves your
character whilst your right thumb aims
and shoots bunny raiders offers solo
couch co-op and online raiding for up to
four players the premise is to save
fellow animals and destroy an end boss
and all his henchmen without dying as
soon as the whole squad goes down it'll
be back to the start you go any trophy
hunters here there's a super easy
platinum trophy to get in bunny raiders
too it'll take you like an hour if you'd
like to try it it's out right now on ps5
with other systems a possibility in
2022. as we're talking about free stuff
you should be aware of a five-hour free
trial for cyberpunk 2077. the open world
shooter has had a soft re-release since
all the issues over a year ago which we
don't talk about a new next-gen version
is available on ps5 and xbox series x
and the full game itself is at the crazy
low price of 25 which is 20 quid over
here in the uk until march the second if
the game functions how it should i
definitely think the five hour trial is
worth your time at the very least there
is a lot to do in cyberpunk and a quick
update on a free game i told you about
last month rumbleverse rumbleverse was
ready for early access in february but
only days before its launch it was
pulled pre-order money was returned and
a new release date was never added it's
just pending right now the team have
gone back to online tests and hope to
have the game ready soon i'll keep you
updated on the free to play 40 40-player
wrestling based battle royale
back to full price games now and
babylon's fall this has me interested
due to who makes it platinum games the
creators of nier automata bayonetta and
metal gear revengeance the combat in
those three games is exquisite so it's
safe to say babylon's fall should be the
same online with friends we team up and
we are asked to scale a tower and defeat
all enemies a cooperative hack and slash
constantly finding loot to increase
abilities and fighting styles there's
going to be tons of free upgrades
dropping regularly after the release of
babylon's fall so it could be something
special match the third on ps4 ps5 and
pc
on march 4th gran turismo returns it's
the eighth game in the series and the
13th release so obviously it's called
gran turismo 7. let's put all our cards
on the table right away gran turismo is
not an easy game to pick up and play it
has almost zero arcade aspects to it gt7
is a pure simulation game it's for those
who want the closest thing to realism
they can get everything from the correct
tire choice to match the weather to the
sound of the engine itself is perfectly
recreated over 400 real life and concept
cars are available to drive including 60
brands you'll recognize 34 tracks have
been lovingly recreated with dynamic
weather systems for each country and
time zone the most interesting aspect
for me is buying a used vehicle to win
races and then using that money to
reinvest in better cars there's cups for
specific vehicle types there's cups for
rear and front wheel drive the minutia
of realistic racing is gran turismo 7.
this is a playstation exclusive which
drops on march 4th on ps5 and ps4
and finally shadow warrior 3 i hope this
isn't the first time you are hearing of
shadow warrior a first person shooter
which doesn't try to be more than that a
fun and gruesome shooter that's like
duke nukem crossed with doom playing as
low wang yep that's his name we use a
crazy large arsenal of firearms and
swords to track down an ancient dragon
which was accidentally awoken it doesn't
take itself very seriously which really
adds to the amusement of adult humor
spread throughout if this is your jam
look out for it on match first it's a
previous gen title on ps4 xbox one and p
to the theme so there we have it 10
games that want your time over march
there's tons more but those are the 10 i
chose if you're still here you have my
thanks and here's a question too if you
could play only one game for the rest of
your life what would you choose and why
i'll be in the comments i'm adam you're
awesome see ya
[Music]